one of my earliest jobs was working at a
pizza parlor called BJ's and everybody
knows BJ's means blow jobs but this
place just meant BJ's and it had they
had some cards on there and that meant
blackjack so I'm guessing the best with
the B and the J stood for Black Jacks
and I was a pizza maker
and cleaner basically everything
[ __ ] work I was the lowest guy on
the totem pole used to make pizzas now
one of the assistant managers was a
born-again Christian he was born and
reborn and unborn and over born double
born I mean just a little zygote for
Christ by the end of it all and this
beautiful creature didn't know anything
about pop culture and he used to wear
Garfield t-shirts all the time and what
we would do is me and this other dude
who was on methamphetamines and this
other dude mouth my coworker he would
always have his pizzas rolled faster
than me right he'd have his pizza done
you know in two seconds you know and
they'd be like you need to the manager
would call me in the office he like you
need to do your pizzas fast as this guy
and I'm like whoa this guy is on drugs
and the money you're paying me I can't
afford the drugs that he's on so unless
you raise my pay I'm not gonna be able
to do drugs and compete and be
competitive here in the in the pizza
workplace so and this dude like I would
barely have my dough rolled out and he
would have his folded it into like a
swan you know like this dude was damn
you know Vincent van dough on that on
that yeast you know on that on that
flowering yeast but it was captivating
to be in that environment and I like
this job was uh it was probably my first
job in a real business you know and this
is post HAMP's this is after I sold
hamsters and guinea pigs and this is
after I cleaned out wishing wells and
this is after I used to Brett I broke
into a man's house and just stole stuff
from him one time and that was it's not
really a job but you do end up with you
know some money and some goods and and
you don't you know and so it's kind of
like a job but anyhow so we would make
up fake pizza orders for this for this
born-again Christian
assistant manager on Sunday and we would
have orders like Danny Glover and he
would take him out into the middle he
would take the orders out there five or
six pizzas for Danny Glover
I don't know lolled Man River old
Military Road or something he would go
out there take the pizzas come back an
hour later and there was no wrong
address no Danny Glover and then we
would eat the pizzas while he was going
we would drink and we would deep-fry
everything in the deep fryer and eat and
that was a really good time that was one
of the best times that I had over there
doing that kind of work thank you guys
for checking out this clip and if you
want to see another clip then you can
look at this clip or this clip either
one of these so did you pick one or he's
still just watching me do this because
this is alarming